it is monday the 23rd of august
boris johnson is appealing to joe biden
to keep us forces in afghanistan past
the end of august the president
meanwhile keeping his options open
our hope is we will not have to extend
but there are going to be discussions i
suspect on how far along we are in the
process
the sky news has spoken to a taliban
leader who says the 31st of august
deadline is not
up for discussion
if they
are intent on continuing the occupation
so it will
provoke reaction
the health secretary promises to crack
down on cowboy companies using the
government's websites to advertise
misleading covert travel test prices
the paralympics getting underway in
tokyo this week with team gb once again
looking to get amongst the goals
and finally we have a fine weather
forecast and it looks like these settle
conditions will stay with us until the
bank holiday weekend all the details
coming up shortly
[Music]
morning all boris johnson will attempt
to persuade joe biden to keep some
forces in afghanistan past the 31st of
august when the two meet in a virtual g7
tomorrow speaking in washington last
night the u.s president said he hopes
there will be no need to extend the
airlift operation into next month but
admitted discussions are taking place
president biden said the u.s has now
airlifted 28 000 people from kabul while
the latest ministry of defense figures
i'm sure the uk has evacuated more than
5
700 from afghanistan
meanwhile sky news has spoken to one
taliban leader who says the group will
not tolerate any extension regardless of
what is agreed between the u.s and the
uk our first report this morning from
our u.s correspondent mark stone
for this third appearance in a week
there was a fresh recognition from the
american president of the challenges his
decision has created good afternoon and
yet he did remain defensive let me be
clear
the evacuation of thousands of people
from kambal
is going to be hard and painful no
matter when it started when we began
would have been true if we had started a
month ago
or a month from now
it is now an international effort at the
airport in kabul
and president biden is under clear
pressure from allies to extend the
august 31st deadline to have troops out
there's discussions going on among us
and the military about extending
our hope is we will not have to extend
but there are going to be discussions i
suspect on how far along we are in the
process
of course it's not clear how the taliban
or its offshoots would react to an
extension or to the president's
confirmation that the airport perimeter
has been widened and his hints at
extractions from across the country for
security reasons i'm not going to go
into the detail of what these plans
entail
but i will say again today that i have
said before
any american who wants to get home
will get home
there certainly seemed to be a shift in
tone this time he was more empathetic to
the situation on the ground and more
robust in his assurances that anyone who
arrives in america will be security
screened in a third country before they
get here his approval ratings have
plummeted in this crisis he knows he
needs to appeal to liberals who wonder
where his empathy has gone and to
conservatives who fear social pressure
and security issues with so many afghans
arriving
and at dulles airport near washington
some of the more fortunate families
stepped into a new world this weekend
the challenges ahead for them will be
huge and their presence here will
further stir a divided nation the
president's gamble is that the chaos
will soon be sorted then forgotten and
he'll be remembered for getting the
troops out
my job is to make judgments no one else
can or will make i made them i'm
convinced i'm absolutely correct and not
deciding to send more young women and
men to war
for a war that in fact is no longer
warned he has been driven by domestic
politics but up against that now the
global impact and america's credibility
mark stone sky news in washington
well let's speak now to the armed forces
minister james heavy mr [ __ ] good to see
you this morning uh and of course plenty
to discuss in terms of those
conversations with the u.s president but
i wonder if we might begin just just
with an update on the state of the
evacuation process
how many and how many we perhaps expect
to get out over the next 24 hours
indeed so in the last 24-hour period
across eight flights the royal air force
have extracted 1821
people from kabul
the flow remains good coming into the
ehc at the barron hotel and we expect to
have a further nine flights over the
next 24 hours
um i wonder if you might confirm uh
reports uh kicking around this morning i
think in the times that the evacuation
program has been has been significantly
expanded last week we were hearing four
thousand then six thousand uh to more
than twelve thousand can you confirm
that
well it is certainly the case that uh as
the cases have been made for more people
from afghan civil society to be
evacuated those names have been added um
in reality the focus is on the around
1800 eligible person so uk passport
holders british nationals and the
remaining people under the arab scheme
which is about 2275
but there are
thousands more who
we would like to get out if there is the
time and the capacity
when you say thousands more can you put
a figure on it slightly more specific
than that
the number changes all the time as
people are sort of brought to our
attention and the fact is we will get
out as many as we possibly can
but we've been clear throughout that
there is a hard reality that we won't be
able to get out everybody that we want
to and that's why it's very important
that we start to reassure people in
kabul because i know that people in
afghanistan are acutely aware of what is
being said in our media here in the uk
that the airlift is not the only route
out of afghanistan it is not the only
route to the uk there is a second phase
to this where people will be able to be
resettled in the uk
having been processed uh either at a
handling center in a refugee camp or
at one of our embassies or high
commissions in the region
if we have learned anything about this
government over the past 18 months it is
perhaps that on occasion perhaps more
than occasion you know policy decisions
taken at the very top happen at a
glacial pace there will be people who
will be pleased to hear the expansion of
the numbers under arab but you know the
former chief of the defense staff lord
danette was talking about this at the
tail end of july i mean so too this this
conversation to take place
with the u.s president why is that
happening tomorrow why is that not
happening today why did it not happen
over the weekend why did it not happen
well last monday when your boss the
defense secretary shed tears when he
conceded back then that not everyone
would be able to come out because of the
time frame on the operation
well firstly i don't uh accept that
characterization of decision making what
i've seen over the last
uh ten days as this uh operation pitting
has been uh going on has been an
extraordinary pace of decision making
across government uh decisions are being
taken in in real time to answer problems
as they arise on the ground and
absolutely everybody here in whitehall
is focused on minimizing the amount of
policy friction
for our people doing a very difficult
job on the ground now
there is a wider question over
whether or not we knew that afghanistan
would fall at the pace that it did um i
don't think we did i think our kind of
worst case assumption was that it would
take around six months to reach the
point that we're at right now and i
don't know that
a lot earlier then it became clear a lot
earlier than tomorrow that we would need
to perhaps expand the amount of time
that we are on the ground again i'll ask
the question why has the prime minister
not spoken to the president of the
united states about this beforehand it
rather looks like the u.s president
isn't willing to take his call is that
the case
the foreign secretary has spoken to
secretary blinken yesterday the defense
secretary spoke to secretary austin so
we have been having these conversations
with the americans but just to be clear
i i think that everybody needs to
understand that this isn't just a
decision that gets taken in washington
the taliban get a vote on this as well
and i think it's far from certain that
the taliban are going to be willing to
allow the international community to
extend beyond the end of the month and
of course we have they're not willing we
know that they're not willing because
news of this uh lobbying of the u.s
president emerged we were able to put a
question directly to the taliban in doha
they have said that august the 31st is a
red line their red lines tend to be
written in blood
presumably the point at which we could
have approached the taliban about all of
this was you know a week and a half ago
where they were trying to work out where
the toilets were in the presidential
palace rather than know when they have
complete security control of kabul
no i don't recognize that
this conversation could have been
happened happened a week or so ago
because i think nobody knew at that
point the sort of scale of the challenge
in fact if you look at the number of
people that have been extracted in the
last week 6 631
that was pretty much the number that was
our target when this operation began so
what's happened in the meantime
is that people have come forward who
have an eligibility under our app
they've been added to the list and
that's why there are still about 2 000
of them to extract which we're working
on very hard to do and then beyond that
there has been an awful lot of people
from civil society that were not in our
plans to be clear they were not in our
plans there wasn't an eligibility they
weren't part of our app but the uk
government is trying to do the right
thing and i don't think we should
apologize for that but we have said we
will try to bring out as many as we can
now that poses a big military challenge
for the generals admirals air marshals
that are planning this mission but i
don't know that it's a bad thing to want
to stretch ourselves to bring out as
many people as possible rather than just
to have stuck with our original number
no one is suggesting that it is a bad
thing minister what we are suggesting is
that we are we are lobbying the u.s
president to extend beyond august the
31st
after the taliban have said that they
will
they will respond and presumably
violently if that were to be the case i
mean
is our time in afghanistan solely
predicated on the americans if they
leave do we have to leave have we really
not investigated any other options
perhaps under nato for example about
remaining in that country if the u.s
decides once again to cut and run well
it is certainly the case that
the mission in kabul this week
is fundamentally underpinned by a u.s
presence not just in terms of the number
of troops that they have at the airport
assuring its security but also the role
that the u.s air force are playing in
delivering air traffic control and all
of the other airfield services so there
is a hard reality that there would be no
international airlift without the way
the united states are are underpinning
it now
whether or not the us can be persuaded
to stay is a matter for the prime
minister tomorrow in the g7 meeting
after the initial overtures made by both
the foreign secretary and the defense
secretary over the days previous but the
conversation with the taliban will then
follow and the taliban will have a
choice they can either seek to engage
with the international community uh and
show that they want to be
a
part of the international system they
want to be engaged in international
diplomacy or they can turn around and
say no there's no opportunity for an
extension so but i think everybody has
to be clear that this is not just the
discussion that happens amongst g7
leaders tomorrow it's a discussion that
then happens with the taliban if there's
the opportunity to stay we will but
right now our military planning is
focused on leaving on the 31st because
that's the deadline that is currently
written down uh as when everybody must
be out
it occasionally feels like the prime
minister's perhaps not not as well
informed about what is going on on the
ground as he perhaps should our
correspondent stuart ramsey has produced
some fantastic work in and around the
airport making clear that the dire
scenes
that are facing many many thousands of
course the majority of whom will not
make it into the airport itself on
friday the prime minister said that
things at the airport were getting
better where if he'd switched on sky
news he would have been able to see that
they were not they were getting markedly
worse at that point did the prime
minister misspeak was he misinformed or
did he lie
no i also was on television on friday
saying that things were getting better
and they were in so much as on the
24-hour period before friday we got a
thousand people out which was a big
acceleration on the number of people
that we got out
on any given on any other day that week
and in fact over the weekend we then got
another thousand out on satur on friday
and 1800 out
on
saturday and another 1800 out on sunday
so in that sense that shows that the
flow into the hc at the barren hotel was
improving now the problem was as
everybody saw in the reporting coming
out of kabul that there was also
incredible proud challenges on saturday
that caused seven people to die
in the crash outside the barren hotel
and i've seen the reporting that
around the wider airport there were more
people killed further
um that is horrendous our troops are
operating in the most awful
circumstances
what has changed over the weekend is
that the taliban have pushed the outer
cordon further away from the baron hotel
which puts a bit more depth into the
process and also if i may now um they've
also separated the us and the uk queues
which makes a big difference to the
crush because a lot of the crush that
was outside the british gate were
actually people trying to access the us
system it's important to know as indeed
your excellent correspondent has done
that once those changes were made the
situation yesterday was much safer and
we're all very relieved about that
how has all of this affected affected
your view of our relationship with the
united states i know from speaking to
them that senior members of the cabinet
are livid
about the decisions taken by president
biden particularly the tone that he
struck in that that that very first
statement
why is no one saying this publicly you
yourself served you will share the view
of many people that you do not leave
people behind you do not cut and run
and that is what the u.s president has
demanded of us
well i mean you're absolutely right that
as an ex-soldier there's a sort of
deeply
ingrained psyche that you never leave a
man behind and that's why we're working
every minute that we can
to maximize the number of people that we
that we bring out and there is a reality
to the fact that this airlift has to end
and that's why it's important to say
that there are other routes to reach the
uk in due course but on the wider issue
of uk u.s relationships
no one's made any secrets of the fact
that we would have
preferred a more conditions based
withdrawal that point was made at the
nato summit
but nato agreed collectively the
president is not wrong that we went in
together and we should all come out
together but from where i sit in the
ministry of defense i can tell you that
right now there is a royal navy ship off
haiti working for the united states
facilitating their relief effort after
the earthquake i can tell you that
there's a u.s warship and a u.s marine
corps air detachment under command of
the royal navy in the philippine sea
operating within our carrier strike
group the us and the uk are working
together in sub-saharan africa in the
north atlantic in eastern europe around
the world
the u.s and the uk remain the closest of
allies of course
when you disagree with your closest
friend it hurts it causes consternation
on both sides of the relationship but
absolutely nobody should think that the
us and the uk have anything but the
deepest and strongest of relationships
and there's stuff going on around the
world that shows that even if right now
in afghanistan there might be a little
bit of disagreement
minister good to have you in the program
this morning uh sorry for keeping you
quiet so long to appreciate it no
problem at all thank you
now what exactly do the taliban make of
the prospect of u.s or uk troops staying
in afghanistan past the 31st of august
deadline someone who knows our
correspondent sally what awkward who sat
down with a taliban spokesman in doha in
qatar sally good to see you this morning
i suspect i already know the answer to
this question but they're not going to
be particularly amenable to any
extension are they
absolutely not
in short neil and it's very interesting
to hear that boris johnson may try
appealing to joe biden at this emergency
summit tomorrow appealing to him to
extend this 31st of august deadline in
order to continue these desperate
evacuations which we have seen going on
for the last week well i sat down with
the taliban spokesperson here in doha
where they've had an office for several
years now and he was emphatic he said
that the withdrawal of troops
from afghanistan must be done by the
31st of august that that is a red line
that in short if the u.s or the uk were
to seek to extend that deadline in order
to continue these evacuations well the
answer is no and there would be
consequences
so if they extend it that means they are
extending occupation while there is no
need for for that i think that it will
deteriorate the relation that will uh
create mistrust between us if they
are intent on continuing the occupation
so it will
provoke reaction
now i got to put several questions to dr
sahil shaheen about these desperate
scenes that we've been seeing at kabul
airport this fear that people have of
their potential or their future rule in
afghanistan i said to him it's not
normal to see people clinging to
aircraft leaving a country during
political transition i said what would
you say to these people he said they
have nothing to fear they have nothing
to be scared of and he said to me that
he he dismissed their fear and called
them economic migrants he said this is
what's driving them is their desire to
live in a western country not because
there's any fear of a taliban rule i
also asked him about women's hard-fought
rights in afghanistan the fact they can
now have careers they can go to
university they can wear what they want
they can socialize with who they want i
asked him what they stand to lose under
taliban rule he said they will lose none
of their freedoms only be asked to wear
a hijab that was it he said they could
continue to work they could continue to
be educated i also asked him about these
worrying reports we've been hearing
about the taliban going house to house
threatening people he dismissed it as
fake news and of course as this deadline
approaches in just around eight days
time i asked him what he would say to
the families of those who died trying to
help afghanistan he said
they occupied our country but the past
is the past and now they want to look to
the future which very much seems to be
the date after 31st of august is the
future they are looking to a date that
they say is a red line non-negotiable
troops must be out of the country
sally manny thanks indeed
uh well in the afghan capital thousands
of people remain stranded at the airport
desperate to escape a military commander
there has said the uk troops leading the
evacuation effort are facing challenges
nobody has experienced before our chief
correspondent stuart ramsey reports
it's a sort of purgatory day night it
makes no difference in their thousands
they just have to wait
and they're sleeping rough hoping for
news
hoping they can get into the system a
system that will get them out of
afghanistan the truth is
most of them probably won't
thousands of children parents and
grandparents grabbing sleep or basically
passing out from exhaustion
the struggle never stops
no food little water
but it is cooler at night
when the sun comes up the true horror of
the conditions they're living in is
obvious
and it is absolutely dreadful they're
penned in this is the american section
of the processing chain
higher security alerts means there's no
movement allowed
there is no shade here only what can be
fashioned from scarves and plastic
soldiers slowly try to work through the
paperwork of the evacuees but the
conditions are getting stricter and more
and more are failing the test of
eligibility
but for everyone here even these awful
conditions are better than what may
await them outside the military lines
outside this taliban is kicking the
people with a rifle with everything i
put in
i put i put in a wood with a for with
the people you kind of check him outside
this taliban is very fighting with the
people
at the british end of the process the
taliban and paratrooper cooperation is
actually working quite well
you couldn't make this up taliban
fighters oversee the crowds from sea
containers that paris put in to create a
screening barrier
where it's an incongruous site having a
taliban right next to it in fact through
the british lines
you can see in front it's much calmer
here uh the british military
are able to process people and i think
what they've done
is got the message through to the local
people if you're rioting and shouting
and screaming and people are getting
hurt there's no way that this can be
processed properly so for now at least
it's calm i mean
there'll be anxiety it'll change it
always does
but uh this is a lot better to yesterday
a lot better
containing the crowds is vital here
clearing up this evacuation mess
requires some pretty lateral thinking
obviously after 20 years of fighting
this is something of a culture shock for
the soldiers but also for the taliban
the main thing for us is to make sure
that we have a smooth possible system to
get those entitled people through
and um at the moment that that involves
an element of the taliban um being here
alongside us as you would have seen
while you've been here and ultimately we
have our our thoughts of
previous tours aside because ultimately
everybody is trying to get the same
situation here which does avoid a
humanitarian crisis and bring those
people through it needs to be but it's
just not the strangest thing
strange times it's strange times
but like i say um
if we weren't here
you know who would be you know we it
needs to be done and
as you said
everybody is feeling it but ultimately
you put that to one side and get on with
the job
this is now a multi-national nightmare
not just the u.s and britain
in the crowds they try to identify
themselves to the soldiers and foreign
services of countries they have links to
their days are spent hoping someone will
spot them and take them out of this hell
hole and onto a plane
the wait is often days and days
in the horrendous rush to get here
families have been split
posters for missing children are dotted
amongst the crowds
people search for their loved ones in a
days of panic
but this is a tough environment only a
few will make the flight only some will
go as a complete family
and nobody knows how long they have
it is purgatory
mr ramsay sky news
and of course much more from stuart uh
all this week uh but still to come on
this program with the prime minister set
to urge president biden to push back the
deadline for u.s troops to be pulled out
of afghanistan a quarter to eight will
be speaking to the uk's former
ambassador to washington sir peter
westmore
[Music]
education under the taliban aid groups
hope that they can continue providing
schooling to children
across the country
marching for climate change i'll be
speaking to an 11 year old traveling 200
miles on foot to raise awareness
now nearly 20
of companies offering covid testing for
travel have been accused of cowboy
behavior by the health secretary over
the pricing of their tests uh joining us
our reporter aisha zaheed uh actually
good to see you this morning um what is
going on here it's a it's quite an
accusation from the health secretary
yeah that's right well after a
government review they found that many
providers listed on their website
providing covert tests for holiday
makers had misleading prices a lot were
listing the prices much lower and then
when you actually went through the
checkout processes they went up after
additional fees were added and it led to
57 providers being removed from the list
some of these don't even exist anymore
or aren't providing the correct covert
test holidaymakers need
and 82 have been given a two-strike
warning it means if they advertise
misleading prices again they will be
removed from the list it's a two-strike
system
after having one strike the companies
have three days to act upon this
and if not they are served that second
strike and there will also be regular
spot checks as well to ensure prices are
accurate to ensure providers are also
following the rules and to make sure
that those who have been removed don't
just change their names
and come back to be added back onto that
list
now this cowboy behavior sergey javid
has said that the crackdown will be
harsh on these companies that are taking
advantage of holiday makers and as well
as this a separate review will be
conducted by the
by the competition and markets authority
and they will be particularly focusing
on concerns around the high cost of pcr
tests
aisha many thanks indeed
let's take a quick run through some of
these other main stories now and new
zealand's prime minister jacinda ardern
has extended the country's level four
lockdown until at least midnight on
friday the shutdown has been extended
even further in auckland which is
currently experiencing a surge in cases
of the highly transmissible delta
variant across the city yesterday 35 new
cases were recorded taking the total
number of infections in the current
outbreak to 107.
at least 21 people are thought to have
died as a result of flooding in
tennessee as rainfall hit record levels
for the u.s state on saturday homes were
washed away and properly destroyed among
those thought to have died
twin babies who were swept from their
father's arms as he tried to take them
to safety
stormwater has continued its journey
through northeast america causing
flooding in states such as new york and
new jersey president biden has declared
disasters in much of the region
promising federal help just as soon as
possible residents have also been warned
that disruptions caused by the storm
could last for days
uh let's check in see how the weather is
looking at the start of the week joe is
standing by give me some good news joe
i have good news the weather is looking
good this week we've actually got high
pressure and control we've waited and
we've waited till late august to see
this and once it's here it looks like
it's going to last until the bank
holiday weekend let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you yes high
pressure in control it's centered over
northern parts of the country which is
going to give us a northerly flow which
is a little bit cooler than we might
have had if we've been dragging some air
up from the mediterranean say and
through the course of the week we will
find a little bit of early mist and fog
some cloud around first thing this
morning that will clear and as i say
we're looking at some really good funny
spells today temperatures nothing to
write home about but in light winds
it'll feel quite pleasant we're looking
at the low 20 celsius with a high say of
around 24 that's 75 degrees fahrenheit
as we go into this evening and overnight
though we are going to see the mist and
the fog reforming a little bit of low
clouds spilling over those north sea
coast so tomorrow we do it all again
they missed the fog the cloud disappears
and we're looking at another sunny day
and a little bit warmer
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
joe thanks very much indeed after the
break we'll be discussing this at that
meeting of the g7 they'll be discussing
how to handle the taliban takeover off
afghanistan now that's after this
[Music]
my fingers
[Music]
and you know i think that we're really
ecstatic to be back on stage we're
really ecstatic that we can go out and
do stuff now and
i mean you know the 18 months was
difficult but we used the time well
because we we made a new album called
the journey so that you know every cloud
has a silver lining as you say so so we
did that it's over four years ago since
you know things changed for us in that
department so
yeah kevin's came in um he's done a
fantastic job and he's he's given a new
lease of life to
we've written some new songs which was
you know i felt that
after the
last thing i stepped out
it was time for us to do something
musical and you know that's what kevin
enabled us to do so he's been doing an
amazing job it was obviously really
difficult because i think we kind of got
a little bit of momentum going
just before
the pandemic hit so
we were out sort of gigging a lot doing
festivals
in the uk and abroad
uh doing our own tours and
and yeah i felt like we'd sort of
gathered you know gained a bit of
momentum and then obviously so
everything just stopped and it's a
little bit like that to be honest it's
like graham said we've done quite a few
festivals recently and i still get those
those pre-show nerves of like how many
people know
you know the different lineup to the
band and you know it does it does sort
of i feel like i'm sort of having to
prove myself every time i go on stage
but um
but you know i'm enjoying the um
what would i say the challenge of it
[Music]
not only design but biology
to create new materials which actually
are fully sustainable and biodegradable
because of privit there is a mass
increase of single-use plastics being
discarded so for me it seemed like a
great opportunity to have a material
which didn't have a longevity of plastic
that could degrade back into the earth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back in just the last few
minutes the armed forces minister james
hippie has given the clearest indication
yet that uk troops will have to pull out
of kabul on the 31st of august if the
government is unable to persuade the
americans to stay beyond that dead let's
take a look
this is certainly the case that
the mission in kabul this week is
fundamentally underpinned by a u.s
presence not just in terms of the number
of troops that they have at the airport
assuring its security but also the role
that the u.s air force are playing in
delivering air traffic control and all
of the other airfield services so there
is a hard reality that there would be no
international airlift without the way
that the united states are are
underpinning it now
whether or not the us can be persuaded
to stay
is a matter for the prime minister
tomorrow in the g7 meeting
after the initial overtures made by both
the foreign secretary and the defense
secretary over the days previous but the
conversation with the taliban will then
follow and the taliban will have a
choice they can either seek to engage
with the international community
and show that they want to be
a
part of the international system they
want to be engaged in international
diplomacy or they can turn around and
say no there's no opportunity for an
extension
uh well as usual as you can see tamara
cohen joining us in the studio morning
again tamara um what do we make of that
it's pretty pretty stark from the armed
forces minister although he of course he
is not the defense secretary he's not
the foreign secretary he's not the prime
minister yes but he was pretty clear
that when the u.s decides it's time to
close that air bridge from kabul airport
that's taking people out then everyone
else will have to leave as well because
the u.s are keeping the airport running
they are running the air traffic control
they're running all of it and although
he made clear that boris johnson will be
seeking to persuade joe biden to extend
the deadline beyond the 31st of august
when they speak at that emergency g7
meeting tomorrow as he said there's
already been discussion of this with the
foreign secretary and the defense
secretary speaking to their u.s
counterparts and it didn't sound like
much had been achieved so far so can the
u.s president be persuaded and bluntly
if he can't then that is it now i know
that the cabinet are working up plans
for people who don't get on these
flights and i thought it was interesting
that he confirmed to you that we're
looking at far more people than we were
even a week ago we've already got out
600 people and there are thousands more
to go because it's expanding all the
time with people in humanitarian groups
and so on making the case that their
employees should be allowed to get on
the planes too so it's far more people
than we expected but he made clear that
when
this ends there may be chances for them
to get out through land borders and
they'll be processing centres in other
countries but how long all that will
take is very unclear at the moment
tomorrow for now thanks very much indeed
uh well as we were just discussing in
fact the leaders of the g7 will be
meeting tomorrow to discuss the
situation in afghanistan top of the
agenda as we've been hearing those
appeals to joe biden to keep us forces
in afghanistan past the end of august
fair to say uh mr biden seems somewhat
reluctant
joining us now on the programme former
eu special representative for
afghanistan the goddess usakis uh mr
yisakis thank you very much for joining
us in the program and apologies for no
doubt butchering the pronunciation of
your name that i do apologize it is very
early on a monday morning but um i
wonder if we can start as someone who
has clearly spent an awful lot of time
dealing with afghans being in
afghanistan
your thoughts on what you have seen over
the past week week and a half
well it's of course it's very sad and
disappointing uh
having spent i mean almost four years in
afghanistan shoulder to shoulder with
the afghans but also with the brits with
americans uh you know to see
to see i mean how we are how we are
losing but i think the time is not not
to celebrate the laws the time is to
help those who deserve to be flown out
of of kabul of afghanistan first of all
i mean citizens uh of the western
government governments but also those
translators the drivers and other
assistants at the same time i think it's
important not to lose the site that
current evacuation should not overwhelm
diplomatic and political efforts we have
truly a window of opportunity
not to recognize immediately but to
engage with afghan with with taliban uh
forces especially political uh element
in kabul because they have provided
initially a pretty constructive sound
bites yes we cannot be complacent when
they say they're going to respect women
rights
according to sharia that will form
inclusive government uh they will not
allow afghanistan uh become again
a source for international terrorism how
and and and will they will accept
humanitarian assistance having said this
not being complacent we have to engage
otherwise
the china and russia will do on behalf
of us
the taliban have also been pretty clear
about uh the date of the august of 31st
we've spoken to one of their spokesman
in in doha and they have made it very
very clear that they view that as the
cut-off point an absolutely definitive
red line for them
well i mean you know i think taliban
also understands that the conflict and
the challenges uh which arise
from afghanistan uh will not be fixed by
artificial or political deadlines hence
we have to be realistic and to see what
needs to be done in order to ensure
evacuation is expanding at the same time
again i think it's important that we do
not only
showcase how effectively we help our
citizens but start planning and start
delivering or at least offering
what we can do on humanitarian
assistance because that's what the
united nations are called about that's
what european union is going to do
anyway to help those people who will be
suffering
across across alliance
diplomatically though what are the
levers that we can use to nudge
the taliban administration towards
something more palatable to western eyes
i mean they are as an organization
in many people's minds completely
antithetical to the western way of life
well i think first of all we have to
recognize that there will be no perfect
solution anytime soon in afghanistan
there will be an afghan solution
which will not correspond to democratic
western uh ideas and democratic
principles secondly what is and i think
what what the lessons have told us
during the last 20 years
the west and g7 alone will not fix
afghanistan we'll have to engage russia
and china
in order to avoid that we continue proxy
wars in afghanistan and we'll have to
talk to the neighbors pakistan iran
whether we like it or not because they
are immediate neighbors
afghanistan is is a country around about
the heart of asia
in low country and we'll have to talk to
them and and find common solution and
the time to talk to
to to taliban is now on the basis of
what i've thought a very constructive
consensual agreement which was issued by
united nations security council on the
16th of august everyone china russia and
the west and other permanent members of
council united states of course uk and
france have agreed to work on
afghanistan and and called and push
taliban to respect women rights
to ensure that the country does not turn
back into the terrorist
seller and the leverage we have is
financial and humanitarian assistance at
the end of the day taliban will realize
that they are not only fighting but they
will have to assume
the public services uh the health
services the financial system which is
in in in
in catastrophe and for for that china
and russia alone will not deliver the g7
won't deliver either so we need to work
together and the u.n is probably the
best uh umbrella uh to reapproach
taliban at this particular stage
mr sanchez good to have you in the
program this morning really appreciate
your time
welcome
still to come on the programme i'm going
to be speaking to the former uk
ambassador to the united states
[Music]
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they fear they'll be
killed
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our
world if there is a bigger explosion
this area would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means precious
aid can't access those and knees
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong that was a
moment
i don't like the chinese government it's
true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber balloons
see fires all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around 31 000
football pitches
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you know that reducing pollution
outside of school can help stop toxic
air getting trapped in our classrooms
[Music]
it's a bit of a grey start to the day
with a fair amount of cloud low cloud
mist and fog around but much of that
will thin and clear to give some bright
or sunny spells in fact the afternoon
looks even better as the cloud melts
away and we're looking at temperatures
into the early 20s perhaps peaking at
around 24 celsius that's 75 degrees
fahrenheit in terms of air pollution
levels
we're looking at a low count just about
everywhere today particularly as we
start to pick up some coastal breezes
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now the prime minister is expected to
use an emergency meeting with world
leaders tomorrow
to try to push the u.s president joe
biden to extend the evacuation deadline
in kabul when it comes after a weekend
of talks between the foreign secretary
dominic rabb the defense secretary ben
wallace and their u.s counterparts let's
speak now extra superior westmacott
formerly of course british ambassador to
the united states so peter good to see
you again um
what what is your assessment of exactly
what is going on in terms of the
transatlantic relationship at the moment
as mentioned the defense secretary the
foreign secretary and tomorrow we are
told the prime minister all to lobby joe
biden to try and extend beyond august
31st what what chance of that happening
well everybody is carrying around now to
show that they are talking to their
american parts uh there obviously was
disappointment that the decision to
evacuate all american military troops
from afghanistan was taken as it was and
it was such a short timetable and after
the president had assured everybody i
assumed cornwall the g7 uh chaired by
boris johnson back in june that the
americans were going to leave enough of
a military presence there for everybody
to stay on in afghanistan in kabul and
that
happened so there is an unseemly
scramble and we've seen what tony blair
has said over the weekend uh and he's a
very proud american former prime
minister so there is obviously
widespread disappointment and there's
been some briefing from government
sources about their disappointment of
the way in which the u.s administration
has handled this and how long it took uh
the president to return boris johnson's
phone call last week and so on so now
with the uk and the chair of the g7
there is a chance for us to try to make
a difference and that will require a lot
of careful homework a lot of preparation
a lot of bilateral phone calls in
advance which is why we've seen this
activity over the weekend partly i'm
sure to do with the criticism of
individual ministers that we've seen in
the uk media about being on the beach at
the wrong time and so on but i think
that's essential preparation is there a
reasonable chance of getting that
deadline on the 31st of august extended
i would say yes because president biden
in his third broadcast yesterday on the
subject said that he was hoping he would
get everybody out by the 31st
but that if there was a need to extend
he would consider that of course
it would help a lot if there is an
understanding with the taliban who are
now in charge in kabul if they agree
because this is a timetable that was
agreed behind the backs of the afghan
government
between the united states and the
taliban and their negotiations in doha
so it does really need to be fixed with
them but the anecdotal evidence that i'm
hearing on the ground is that the
taliban leadership to the extent they
are in control of the people there
are at least sticking to their word and
helping these the expatriates get to the
airport and out the problem is much more
for those afghans for whom we've all got
a moral responsibility used to work for
us or for international organizations
and so on but whose lives are also in
danger and so that's the real challenge
for the next few days and perhaps weeks
you mentioned reassurances that joe
biden presumably as you say it gave it
gave it the g7 in cornwall did it need
to be like this sir peter i've lost
count of the number of times over the
past week and a half that i have been
told by supposedly better informed
people than i that they just didn't see
this coming
i think two comments neil one did it
need to be like this no
um i think most people who have followed
recent events in afghanistan would say
that it wasn't a binary choice between
all out or putting in more troops as the
american president has said there was no
very good reason why you couldn't carry
on much as we had been for a number of
months after the british for example
finished all combat operations in
afghanistan i think it was seven years
ago and the americans some time back and
there was pretty minimal risk very
little loss of life thank god in the
status quo which was manageable and
which was giving afghanistan a chance of
getting it back together so you could
have carried on like this for quite a
long time and there was disappointment
initially back in april when biden
followed on the trump policy of
withdrawal he just extended the deadline
from the 1st of may to the anniversary
of 9 11. it didn't need to be like this
it could have continued not brilliant
but at least with minimal loss of life
and with a chance of afghanistan kind of
working and with women and girls having
a modicum of prospect human rights
education jobs
uh there were of course lots of people
being murdered independent-minded mps
journalists lawyers were being butchered
on a daily basis by the taliban not good
at all but um i didn't think it was as
binary a choice as the president made
out and i think that's the view
in london so i think
that is the reality we could have gone
on like this not perfect but a lot less
bad than what we're looking at at the
moment
so peter
what diplomatics way do we actually
possess in washington dc at the moment
the defense secretary the foreign
secretaries as mentioned both rebuffed
the point i put to the uh to the armed
forces minister this morning why has the
prime minister not made this request of
president biden before now
i don't know what conversations there
were in the margins in in cornwall
during the g7 but it looks as though
the uk government along with others did
not see this coming as uh as quickly as
it did happen whether or not there was
an intelligence failure i don't know
there's been lots of people out there
saying oh no the intelligence people did
know what was happening and they advised
president not to do this and he
disregarded that advice
i'd like to think that advice was given
to senior british ministers to lobby
very hard in washington did they do so
well not i don't know but one of the
realities of likely over the years
whether it is george bush whether it is
ronald reagan whether it was even barack
obama
is that the american system does tend to
take its foreign policy decisions on its
own through the process of its own
national security council and then tell
its allies what it's done and invite us
to go along with those policy decisions
they're not brilliant and it's partly
because of machinery rather than
political will at seriously consulting
their eyes and so we're often left in
different subjects different places
different parts about scrambling uh to
be the loyal and faithful ally and i
think what's happened now is first of
all disappointment that biden was not
different to some of the earlier
presidents having talked a lot about
consensual foreign policy and working
with allies but also the realization
that with the united kingdom having
declined to perform any kind of foreign
and security policy arrangement with the
rest of european union when we left we
said no thanks we don't want anything to
do with you all on that we're now a bit
on our own are left with the united
states who turned out to be particularly
on this subject there i say it's
something of a disappointment
so peter westmacott great to have you on
the program once again uh we will no
doubt see you again soon thanks for
joining us
time for us though to have a quick look
at the weather here's joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well the
weather is looking good we've got high
pressure in control but it is centered
at the north of the country which is
going to give us rather a cool northerly
flow rather than dragging up some heat
from the south but certainly first thing
this morning we've got a bit of low
cloud around some mist and fog so it's a
bit murky in places but much of that
should lift through the course of the
morning we'll see some sunshine the
sunshine better still through the
afternoon temperatures widely in the low
20 celsius and we could see a high of 24
degrees celsius 75 degrees fahrenheit
which will feel very pleasant in light
winds
the weather sponsored by qatar airways